[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the only test if a man's worth its
battle those rounds come screaming past
your head you're gonna learn if you're
hungry enough hungry enough to take that
victory
we're going to battle with the soldiers
that we used to be ghosts and you better
believe that they are hungry too
once upon a time some of these ghosts
they may have been your friends and
there is brotherhood but then there is
what the world needs these ghosts they
are the past they still serve the
Machine that we left behind and right
now for the future the world needs us
I'm honored I'm honored to be here with
you tonight
and as you head into battle with that
mean look in your eye those bad
intentions in your mind remember this
you are the few with the courage to make
history
you had the desire to take victory
you will be on a battlefield full of
ghosts but only you
that makes you lose
[Music]
what's going on everybody hey I'm John
good to be here this is bambam the dog
thank you thank you it's a real honor to
be here with you guys today thank you I
love you too right on this is awesome
this has been really great and exciting
and I'm really I'm really honored to be
here I'm I'm enormous ly proud to be
part of the development of this game it
was a pleasure to work with the Ubisoft
team you know I've had the chance to
play some pretty strong tough men over
the years I've played a Deputy fighting
zombies special Special Forces soldier
who lost everything
and now I get to play a coldie Walker
he's a skilled former Special Operations
soldier with his own sense of
responsibility and his own moral code he
knows how things should be run he loves
his brothers fellow soldiers but he is
willing to do whatever it takes to
complete his mission and take control of
aroa there is no briefing there's no
backup you will not face a group of bad
guys or criminal organization you will
face an entire army my army the wolves
we got the numbers we've got the
organization and remember we trained
alongside you the weaponry of a fully
operational special ops detachment trust
me there's an unparalleled arsenal of
high-tech weapons in aroa
so if you think you have what it takes
strap on your boots and you get ready to
take on the Wolves take on me see you in
a row we'll be waiting for perfect
predators you have the knowledge of
their hunting ground we have the element
of surprise
they have the technology but we have the
skills to even the odds
they ever know
we fight with our brothers and sisters
[Music]
they are hungry but we are enraged
[Music]
we are ghosts
and ghosts never die
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
hi everyone being a community developer
on Ghost Recon wildlands and great point
has been an incredible journey for me so
far when we first announced the game you
were very excited and after discussions
of members of our community I today
announced that with our post launch plan
we will be bringing back our AI
teammates for solo player with Ghost
Recon breakpoint we want to go the extra
mile with how we engage with you so I'm
pleased to announce a brand new
community program that will allow you to
express and share your passion welcome
to Ghost Recon Delta Company
from costly to streaming fanarts of
forum discussions however you show your
love for Ghost Recon there is something
for you in our five different
detachments with lots of content to
support you as well as direct
discussions with our studio so head over
to our Ghost Recon great print website
to find out more and hear from you soon
Delta ghosts thank you very much
everyone
[Applause]
[Music]
Thank You Lora
hello everyone the ghost recon team has
always taken great pride from your
passion for our games and that passion
is what pushes us to deliver the best
SpecOps experience out there behind
enemy lines you will be fighting the
most dangerous enemies the ghosts have
ever faced constantly testing your
survival skills yes we can't wait to
welcome you in Ghost Recon blood point
on October 4th and one more before that
our beta will be live on September 5th
you can register on our website right
now for chance to participate Ghost
Recon breakpoint will be live for years
to come
we've got your back
new content free updates and many
surprises inspired by our community yes
yes like this one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
will you survive your break point
alright see you all out there have a
good one
[Applause]
[Music]